مرحبًا ، أنا دانا سانتس مدرب للتنفس
والعقل والجسم في الرياضات الاحترافية ،
أود أن أتحدث معك عن
تنفسك
عندما تذهب إلى الطبيب
ويطلب منك أن تأخذ نفسًا عميقًا
ما الذي تفعله
يبدو أن هذا هو التركيز الكبير على
الشهيق الذي يرتفع الأكتاف
ثم لا يوجد الكثير من
التفكير في الزفير
الذي لا يمثل نفسًا مثاليًا
بدلاً من ذلك ، يجب أن نركز أكثر على
التنفس الذي
يوسع أضلاعنا.
ما أود أن أعرضه لكم الآن هو
كيف يمكننا في الواقع تحريك
أضلاعنا لجعل أضلاعنا تتحرك
لتسهيل نمط تنفس أفضل
لأن التنفس هو في
الواقع نمط حركة وفي الواقع
كنمط حركة نقوم به
لأعلى من 24  000 مرة في
اليوم يمكن أن يكون لها تأثير كبير على
شعورنا بالألم المزمن الذي قد
تشعر به في رقبتك
أو القيود في كتفك.
لذا ما أود أن تفعله هو وضع
يديك على ضلوعك السفلية ،
فلدينا شق في القفص الصدري لدينا
هنا لأن هذه الأضلاع السفلية مصممة
للحركة ، لذا سنضع أيدينا على
أضلاعنا للتوجيه والمراقبة
حركتهم ثم أريدك أن تبدأ
بزفير وليس شهيقًا فقط ابحث عن الهواء الذي
لا يزال في رئتيك
واتركه لي الآن إما من خلال
فمك أو أنفك
استنشق من خلال أنفك
[موسيقى]
هل شعرت أن ضلوعك بدأت في التحرك للخارج
، فقد لا يحدث ذلك في المحاولة الأولى
، فلنحاول مرة أخرى
حتى
لا نتنفس ثم نبطئ الشهيق من
خلال أنفك ،
ربما شعرت به قليلاً  قليلا هناك ولكن
هذه هي
الطريقة المثلى للتنفس نريد
تحريك ضلوعنا لأن
الحجاب الحاجز لدينا عضلات الجهاز التنفسي الأولية لدينا ترتبط في
الواقع
بهذه الضلوع السفلية وحركتها
تساعد على تسهيل الانقباض
وهو الشهيق
والاسترخاء الذي هو
الزفير وهذا  كيف يجب أن نجلب
الهواء إلى الداخل
عندما تأخذ نفسًا رأسيًا ،
فأنت لا تستخدم الحجاب الحاجز للقيام بذلك ،
فأنت تسحب كل
تلك
العضلات في كتفيك
صدرك ورقبتك
أعلى ظهرك للمساعدة في رفع  القفص
الصدري لسحب الهواء
لهذا السبب تصبح هذه العضلات ضيقة للغاية ،
تذكر ما قلته أكثر من 24000
مرة في اليوم
أنك تستخدم تلك العضلات في وظيفة
لم يتم تصميمها حقًا للقيام
بذلك ، لذا سنحاول  من الآن فصاعدًا
للتنفس
بشكل أفضل باستخدام أضلاعنا لملء الرئتين
بالتركيز على حركة الضلع تلك
، نفسًا أفقيًا بدلاً من
التنفس الرأسي
[موسيقى]